Welcome to Ear Biscuits.
The podcast where two lifelong friends
talk about life for a long time.
I'm Ret.
And I'm Link.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we gonna get weird y'all.
I mean, it's going to happen. Why?
Because we put out a prompt,
we put out a tweet that said,
"Finish this sentence
for an upcoming #earbsicuits discussion:
"Am I weird because I blank?"
And I will say that this was a,
this is a little inside
baseball, a little internal,
and I don't mean like going to the doctor,
I mean, I'm going to tell
you a little background
on how we arrived at this question.
The first question that we
tweeted was something like,
Here it is right here.
Ask us, ask us a question
that you'd be too afraid
to ask your friends.
We might answer it on an Ear Biscuits.
The thing that we were
thinking in that prompt was
we're trying to get to, like,
you guys to talk about things that you
were kind of embarrassed
that you might not know about
or think about yourself or whatever.
But I think the mistake was,
when we said your friends,
because people said things like,
"Are you in love with
me?", or stuff like that.
We wouldn't have any insight.
Am I annoying?
And so we went back to the drawing board
and got more specific with the,
"Am I aware because I blank?",
and you delivered.
Yeah, I think we may be doing
more of those types of prompts,
but I, you would be amazed
at the amount of discussions we have
around putting these prompts out there.
Because you know, it's
kind of like fishing.
You don't know exactly what you,
we have an idea of what we want to get.
Gotta have the right lure.
I want to catch a fish.
Gotta have the right bait.
I don't want to catch
a turtle, so to speak.
So we have to,
And, Can I back out even a
little bit further and say,
Just the fact that we can,
That's you backing out.
we can say,
you know what?
Finish this sentence on social media,
"Am I weird because I blank?",
and then people respond.
People fill in the blank
with things that they legitimately do
and legitimately question whether it
makes them strange or weird.
This is fascinating to you?
They are that willing, I mean,
it's just a reality
check. We're at a place
in our lives where we can
tweet something like that.
And people will respond.
There's plenty of, plenty
of people who could,
anybody can get a Twitter account, Ret.
Are you just talking
about the function of having followers?
Yes.
Anybody, anybody can say,
Hey I'm thankful for followers.
Am I weird? Finish this sentence,
"Am I weird because I blank?",
and then nobody will respond.
Well I think what you're getting at,
Maybe three of their friends.
Sometimes I see people
with one to two followers
like put out a Twitter poll.
And I'm like,
I mean, nothing against
having one or two followers,
but if you've got one or two followers,
your poll results are going to
um,
They're gonna be a little shallow.
Incomplete. Yeah.
Not indicative of much other than
your one or two followers.
I'm gonna say it. You know what?
It's nice to be in a place where
we can ask people questions
that prompt them to put themselves
in compromised positions.
And not only do we get a lot of responses,
but we get a lot of strange responses
that are worth talking about,
while mentioning their username.
Cause using your fishing analogy,
we were trying to bait
you into saying something
or admitting something
embarrassing about yourself.
And it took two tries to get there.
You know, sometimes we,
Boy did we get there.
When you go out to the lake, you know, I,
I told you that I made the mistake
of watching approximately 12 minutes
of professional fishing.
Recently.
That's till happens?
Cause I was like, Oh!
I get, like every once in awhile,
ESPN will have professional
fishing on. And I,
most of my television that I
consume, that's not streaming,
which most of it is streaming.
But if I'm not going to stream,
usually it's,
So it'd be fishing.
It's to watch a sporting event.
And I use the YouTube TV,
not a sponsor YouTube TV app.
And I,
It peaked your piqued your interest.
There was nothing on sports
that I wanted to watch.
But there was bass fishing.
And so I was like, "Hmm, let
me check in with bass fishing."
Why not? Right?
I think everybody needs,
It's worth a shot.
Especially everybody from North Carolina
needs to check in with bass
fishing. At least once a decade.
I checked in and I saw
the most exciting part,
apparently,
of this tournament.
Was these two guys who were trying to win.
Different boats, different locations.
Different boats.
And then,
they were not catching
anything for the like,
five to seven minute
period that I watched.
There was, okay, in that 12 minute period,
there was one guy that
caught a small bass. But,
12 Minutes. One guy catches a small bass?
Yeah. But during the,
while they were waiting,
the guy turns to the camera, or, you know,
just addresses the camera. And he's like,
"You know,
it's different when you're out here
than when you're watching at home."
Like it was like,
and I don't even know what
his point was. Was he saying,
Was he excited?
that it's more boring
to be here, that it is
to watch it at home?
Because at least we were
watching an edited thing?
I don't know what his point was.
But if it's,
It is different though.
If it's edited, why,
I mean, it seems like
they could just, I mean.
With golf you cut to somebody
when they're about to putt.
With fishing, why can't
you just cut to somebody
when they're about to catch?
Well I think it's all,
it's a numbers game.
In golf, there's approximately 70,
There's a lot of fishermen too.
Hold on. No, this is the math.
Your wife was a math major.
I know you can follow this.
There's like about 70
shots per person, right?
I don't know how many
people there are fishing
versus how many golf golfers there are
golfing at a tournament.
But there's 70 times that you can tune in
and see them do something.
No one catches 70 fish!
The guy in the lead had
caught four bass all day.
Ret, Ret.
Your wife watches television.
So I know you can follow this.
You could edit it down to a 22 minute,
sitcom length, of bass tournament.
That's what I'm saying.
What I'm saying is golf can be,
you can watch golf for five hours
and constantly see somebody hitting it.
You watch bass fishing
for an hour and you watch,
and I watched 12 minutes,
which is one fifth of an hour,
and I saw one fish get taken?
There's not enough fishing.
It's like, they need to,
you know, and just like
in order to make soccer more interesting,
Just make it a YouTube video!
They need to make the goal bigger
or get rid of the keeper.
And then everybody's going
to fall in love with soccer.
If you want people to fall
in love with bass fishing,
you gotta use better bait or
there's gotta be bigger fish.
There's gotta, I don't know, I mean.
Editing.
Editing!
But even then, it's still
just people catching fish.
And it's not as entertaining as a,
as an Instagram video that I saw recently
where there was a little girl,
like a year and a half years old,
I don't know how you say
that a year and a half old,
who her dad had caught a very big bass
and she was hugging
it. And she was saying,
"It's okay fish."
"I love you fish."
"It's okay, fish."
And then they put the fish back.
Okay.
So if you can bring a baby
who can talk to the fish,
that's the kind of thing
that I would be into.
Everybody needs to have
a baby in their boat
who addresses the fish
before it's thrown back.
We're gonna read through your
completions of the sentence.
"Am I weird because I blank?"
And you might think that
we're going to judge you
and that we're going to
say, "Yes, you are weird."
or "No, you're not weird."
Well, that's the point, isn't it?
But the real point,
is that we're going to
celebrate weirdness.
You know what?
Yeah, there's nothing
wrong with being weird,
but we are going to tell you if you are.
Ah,
I once heard it said, "Just yourself be,
if weird is you."
Embrace it.
And that's what, this is. This isn't,
this is not ultimately judgment.
This is celebration of strangeness.
And I'm a little biased
because I know I'm weird.
Can I tell you my criteria
for judging these things?
Yeah.
Um, to me
If there's something,
If one of these things
that you do is to like,
it brings you comfort
or something like that.
And you can't argue with something
that brings somebody comfort, right?
If this is like a self-soothing thing.
Well we can say anything we want.
But to me, I'm going to,
there's two things I'm gonna judge.
One.
Is this something that you
would be considered normal?
In other words,
are you an exception to
the majority of people
because you do this? Like,
is this an unusual behavior?
I think that, that's one
way I'm going to look at it.
And then the second is,
like, is,
should we be concerned?
You know what I'm saying? Like,
should we be concerned about you?
Well, let's, let's get into it.
Aubree Stamey
replied to us.
She tweeted,
"Am I weird because I rub my
feet together to fall asleep?"
Are you a cricket?
I think they're rubbing
their legs together.
In order to mate.
I mean, do they even have feet?
Cricket feet,
Or is it,
ends with its, ends with its leg?
Yeah. It's just kinda like,
the leg just kinda like,
there's an ankle I think.
But then on the other side of the ankle,
it's just a little bit more leg.
I don't think, I wouldn't call it a foot.
That's a foot!
I wouldn't call it a foot.
I'd call it a short leg after an ankle.
It's really no different.
Well what's the difference
between a short leg,
after an ankle and a foot that
goes a different direction?
Toes.
You think you have to
have toes to have a foot?
Yeah.
I don't think insects have feet, man.
So you think, well,
Okay.
What if somebody,
I don't have any crickets.
What if somebody loses all their toes?
What if I Google "cricket foot"?
By that rational, if
you lose all your toes
in an accident,
you don't have a foot anymore, man.
That's just more leg now.
Well, I don't want to get,
I don't want to get into like,
Why you gotta go straight to maiming?
Cause I got to find logic somewhere.
All right, I just searched "cricket foot".
Which is a great name for a band.
The only thing that came up was like,
a closeup of a cleat on someone
who's playing,
Cricket.
Australian version of baseball.
I wonder how many actions, I
think I could get into that,
before bass fishing.
Watching cricket.
Now I just said that cricket
was Australian baseball,
but cricket is from, is from where?
Well, I mean, I think
it's of British origin.
Yeah.
Because it's
made its way to, it's
very popular in Australia.
It's very popular in India.
It's very popular in places
that the British colonized.
I'm scrolling down, nothing
is related to the insect.
Cricket.
Can you do cricket leg?
Hold on. "Cricket feet in bed"
is a related search to "cricket foot".
I'm gonna click on that.
Ah!
Oh, we found it.
We found it. We found what this,
Does anybody else,
you lady is asking about.
I didn't know this was a Reddit thread.
There's a Reddit thread called,
"Does Anybody Else", DAE. I'm
going to have to follow this.
"As soon as I hop in bed and lay down,"
this is somebody's post.
Kristen Bryant from four years ago.
And this is answering your
question, "Is this normal?"
We're about to find that out.
"As soon as I hop in bed and lay down,
I have the instant urge to
begin rubbing my feet together.
Most times I don't realize I'm doing it,
but then I catch myself.
If I separate my feet,
I'll just end up rubbing my
foot, feet on the bedsheets.
It's like it relaxes me.
I've been doing it for as
long as I can remember."
Top comment,
"Ya damn crickets."
Right?
Which is the same thing that we said.
So that's the obvious joke.
Someone else commented, "Used to do this
because I have RLS. Sucks.
Restless Leg Syndrome. Which I have.
You have Restless Leg Syndrome?
But interestingly,
Do you do this?
I don't rub my feet
together. I'm move my legs.
My wife, however, does this.
She rubs her feet together. But you know,
the other thing that she does,
How do you know she does it?
Can you hear it?
Yeah, because you can like, see,
you can kind of see her legs
moving and you can feel it
in the bed. But you know, the
other thing that she does,
and this is a little,
She's so much shorter than you,
her feet are probably at,
My knees.
She also, she rubs my feet
with her feet. Excuse me.
She does?
And she gets upset with me
because I cannot go to sleep
if someone else is touching me.
Yeah.
I do all kinds of touching
when I'm not sleeping.
But when I'm done with the touching,
I'm ready for the sleeping and
they're mutually exclusive.
So, I mean, I'm not
saying I'm not a cuddler,
but I'm not a cuddle-sleeper.
But she,
Now that we got a bigger
bed. That's the situation.
We're in a double bed.
We'd be, we'd have like
18 points of contact.
I just can't fall asleep like that.
Cause I'm a super light sleeper,
but she will have her foot
on my foot and start rubbing it.
And I, and my feet are sensitive, man.
I don't like that. I
don't like a foot massage.
Yeah. For the longest time when,
I tried to get a pedicure one time.
I would get a full body
massage, sans feet.
Yeah, leave the feet off the table.
Because they spend a
lot of time on the feet
and that's time that could
be spent somewhere better.
Boy, I miss massages. I
don't get those anymore.
I've been holding back on you here, Ret.
So I don't think this is weird.
I do this.
Oh, you do this?
Yeah.
And I didn't really think
about it, but I, I do this.
And I may have mentioned this on the show
or maybe Good Mythical
More, or maybe just to you
as a friend.
But the new thing that I've
added to my, I get in the bed.
I, my feet kind of rub
together a little bit.
It's not like I rub my feet
together until I doze off.
Like Lando has this habit
from when he was like,
almost as soon as he
had hair. So I wasn't,
I'm going to say a newborn,
but like as soon as Lando
had hair long enough
in like the back, like
the mullet area, he would,
he would twirl his finger in his hair.
And as long as I can
remember, he's done it.
And he still does it.
It's kind of like a way
that he falls asleep.
And as a toddler,
he would twist his finger
in his hair and then
it would put him to bed.
And then he would be crying
and we go back in there
and his finger would be caught.
He would have knotted his finger
and not be able to get it out.
Kristy had to use scissors
and cut his finger off.
No, to cut the knot out.
But I just do it for like,
just to like, Oh, I'm in bed.
I'm finding my spot. My feet
rub together a little bit.
And then I started shifting my hips
and my lower back would pop.
And now every single time,
right before I go to sleep,
I'll like, I'll Shakira my hips.
You need to pop now.
And then it pops right there.
And if you don't get a pop,
you go to sleep with a sense inadequacy.
Yeah, yeah.
I know about this.
I'm becoming like a baseball player.
That's like got this routine.
Or cricket player, to stay on subject.
Cricket footwork is, is its own thing.
It has its own Wikipedia entry,
which I'm not going to read.
So yeah, Aubrey, you know what?
You're not weird.
Jesse has spoken. Link has spoken.
And a lot of of Redditers have spoken.
Kiki Kinnock said, "I
thought everyone did this.
If not, why not? It feels amazing.
My husband and I both do it,
including with each other's feet."
Yeah. See, there you go.
That's what my wife is trying to do to me.
So there you go. If you haven't tried it,
try it and put a little Shakira into it
See look at that. All right, so.
So this might,
Kind of a let down.
It wasn't weird.
This might surprise you
Tom Dolls, Tom Dolls Magic,
who based on his profile, I
think he's a real magician.
I think he seems like a magician. Yeah.
He has a deck of cards
in his profile picture.
He's holding a deck of cards
right next to his cheek lovingly.
Well cause you gotta get in picture,
in the Twitter pictures.
It's Magicians, they have,
I don't think he typically
holds it next to his face.
They have a relationship with cards
that is borderline inappropriate.
So Tom, you are weird
because you're a magician,
but that's not what you're asking.
"Am I weird because I bite my fingernails
and floss my teeth with
them?" Embarrassed emoji.
Well, I do this.
Wow.
I mean, does it work?
Okay. So I do not, I no
longer bite my fingernails,
but I bit my fingernails consistently,
exclusively as a way of
trimming my fingernails
up until three years ago.
Would you consider it a
habit? Cause I considered,
I mean, I bite my fingernails and it's,
it's been a habit that I
haven't been able to break.
It was not a nervous habit. It was a,
this is how I deal with my
fingernails getting too long.
Honestly. It was like, "Ah,
my fingernails are too long."
We don't, we're not an
organized household.
So it's like finding the nail clippers.
It's like, they're not
always in the same place.
I just was like, "Ah okay,
I'll just start biting them.
So it wasn't a nervous thing.
It was a functional thing.
But then you, why did you stop?
Because I, I,
I had the, you might notice this,
if you ever seen close-ups
in my hands, but you're like,
"What the hell is happening
with Ret's fingernails?"
I thought about this before,
but I've got the basically
like psoriasis-based,
psoriasis under my fingernails. Right?
So it does it taste bad?
It tastes great.
Oh god.
But like the fingernail will
detach in some places. Right?
And so what I found is like,
it's happening right there.
See how it's getting white right there?
Oh, it makes it white
because there's space?
And I've found that it's
much easier to manage them
if I use a sharp thing and
then like file them down.
It seems to help with the
problem. I don't know why.
Plus we shouldn't be, you know,
we've gotten strict about
not putting our hands
in our mouths and in our eyes and stuff.
But when I used to do
this on a regular basis,
I would take one,
and then I never even
thought about the fact
that I was doing this
and I would not have called it "flossing",
but definitely I would see which teeth
I could get it in between.
Especially the two front ones.
I'd put it in there and I'd
start moving it back and forth.
Just that, that was a habit.
It was less of a I'm
flossing and more of a habit,
but it was technically flossing.
I was flossing with fingernails.
I'm making a gross-out face
cause it just seems a little gross.
It is gross.
And I am not a magician and
I've never been a magician
and I've never even thought
about being a magician,
but yet I still do this.
I think they're unrelated then.
Okay, well I was just seeing,
trying that on for size.
Well,
I think this is gross.
I think it's weird.
You know? I mean, if
it were your toenails,
it would be even more gross.
You know, people,
the whole cutting and
sniffing your toenails.
I do not bite my toenails. Never did.
But I could. I'm flexible enough.
But I mean, there is this urge
to smell your own toenail.
And I don't know,
I do that.
Why?
Because it's amazing how
awful it can smell sometimes.
And I'm just like, "How, what happened?"
What got caught under there?
But it, but there is something,
there's like a primal
urge associated with it.
It's like, you know that it stinks.
Why does a dog smell
its own shit sometimes?
Because,
I saw Bobber doing it
the other day. I asked
her, she did not respond.
Because they, they learn something.
Well, I learned something about myself
when I smell my toenail clippings.
Like something's wrong with my feet.
I need to do something about it.
But how many times do
you need to learn that?
I think that there's the primal urge is,
is different than that. It's
not, it's not diagnostic.
You're right. You're right.
It's, um,
It's like eating black licorice. Honestly.
For me, it's extremely bad.
Like, if there's something
in a room that smells awful,
I can't help but smell it.
If there's something in a movie
that's really difficult to
watch, I do not turn away.
If I go by a wreck, I look
to see if there's a body
with a sheet over it.
I'm that guy.
Okay. So we're back to the, the,
I think it was called
pseudo masochistic tendency
when we were talking
about eating spicy foods.
Yeah.
So maybe there's something in there.
I'm not a magician., so
Neither of us.
So I wouldn't know for sure.
I do think that this is,
people do it.
It's gross, but gross doesn't
automatically mean weird.
I think weird is kind of
like, if something's gross,
it increases the chances
of it being weird,
if it's also strange.
Like you're inventive.
Like I've never heard of this before.
The fact that you do this.
Did
this.
Okay. Whatever. Then,
I don't know. I'm hesitant
to say, this is weird.
I think it's weird. I
think the average person,
when he seeing that, definitely
if they witnessed this.
Yeah, if someone else sees you do it
I'd be like, "Ah that dude's weird."
Then you become a weird person.
You're on the weird spectrum.
I also think he has an ace up his sleeve,
in this case.
Okay.
We've got more of these to go through,
but we also want to remind
you that we have a website.
We've, we've done it. We finally did it.
We got a website.
mythical.com
We've had it for quite a while.
Oh, that's right.
Yeah. I was just kind of talking like,
in this lifetime we've got it.
It used to be called retandlink.com.
And then we were like, "You know what?
This ain't, this ain't about us.
This is about a world
that we're all a part of."
And then,
Where you can buy things.
Yeah, right. Well, that's
really the reason you should
And identify with the world.
That you're a part of.
We're all in this together.
But the only way to really
know it, is to wear it.
And, if you want to get
something from mythical.com
with standard shipping, and
receive it by Christmas,
you have to order it no
later than December 10th.
I think the coloring book is,
There might be some exceptions to that.
got its own pipeline.
But for most everything else,
December 10th, for
domestic standard shipping,
to get it by Christmas.
mythical.com,
we got all types of gifts and gift cards.
Gift it up.
I'm on,
I'm on the third day in a row
of not taking my allergy pill.
I've noticed you've been sneezing.
And I sneezed
nine times in a row this morning.
I'm never, that does not happen to me.
That's a lot,
I'm slightly allergic to,
There's something floating around.
I'm slightly allergic to dogs.
Like when I got my allergy
test a few years ago,
dogs and cats registered
on the very, very low.
But like I ran out of
my, I'm a Zyrtec man.
And I ran out and I
haven't gotten any more.
And then there was a
part of me that was like,
maybe I should just see
if I can get off of it.
Sometimes when you sneeze a bunch,
it's like your body
needs to do it. So there,
there is a sense of relief and pleasure.
You know, you talk about a primal urge.
There is, there is pleasure
associated with a sneeze,
unless it goes sideways.
You mean out the ear?
And you know, no, sometime,
It can happen.
It just doesn't come out the right way.
But I mean, nine in.
Did you fully experience
like a bell curve of pleasure
and pain?
It felt good every time,
but it was annoying to me and my wife.
How much, what percentage of,
what percentage of air
comes out of your nose,
versus your mouth when you sneeze?
Mostly out my mouth,
unless I've made a decision to,
To force it.
To force it out of my nose
in order to like, get a,
I call that a power blow.
Yeah, I'm really scared of that.
I'm really scared of that.
Yeah.
It doesn't accomplish much
because it's almost all mouth.
A lot of force. If you, if you force like,
like 95% of that force through your nose,
Your eyes might pop out.
You gotta, you gotta deviated septum.
Yeah.
You could lose an eye.
It could straighten it out.
I don't think can
straighten out bone though.
Over time.
There's probably another way to fix it.
Anyway. I need my allergy pills.
It's driving me nuts.
Katelin Pemberton responded to us,
"Am I weird because I can
talk with my mouth closed?"
I've known people who could do this.
I do not understand how it
works. I've witnessed it.
I do not think it's weird.
I think it is remarkable.
Well, I've never witnessed it.
I think we should try it.
Okay. Be my guest.
Not even close.
Can you understand what I'm saying?
You're making a series of humming noises
that's all I hear.
It's I'm hearing somebody through a wall.
My lips are still together,
but I'm trying to speak normally.
Yeah.
I'm not even going to attempt it.
You should attempt it!
Hold on, you're not saying anything.
Yeah, because I can't do it.
Say something.
I'm saying my lips are still together.
Don't say that. I said that.
You say something different.
Why are you eyes getting so big?
Your eyes don't have
anything to do with this.
I said, "I'm saying something different."
Okay. You, we, you need to, if you had,
have you not seen a YouTube
video this before? Like,
what we're talking
about is someone who can
talk articulately
as if there's another
mouth inside their mouth.
You need to watch a,
you should watch a video of
this real quick, just so,
Uh,
Just so you, I mean,
we can cut this out so we
won't get flagged or whatever,
but you just need to, so you
will understand what this is.
Okay. Now stop that.
Stop that.
Oh, I can do that.
You sound like someone who
is making preliminary sounds,
but not completing them with
the tongue and the lips.
She sounds like someone
who has tongue and lips
inside her mouth. Like an alien mouth.
How is that possible?
Yeah, she's got
she's got a talking
talker trapped in there.
No physically. What is happening?
Do you understand it?
Cause this is the real magician.
Well, when I, when I searched
"talk with your mouth closed",
the first thing that
comes up is a WikiHow.
How to speak with your mouth closed.
You'll need to make sure your lips
are parted ever so slightly.
Without parting your
lips just a little bit,
you won't be able to get
any sound out of your mouth.
Practice parting. Oh, so this,
So it's cheating.
WikiHow's never reliable though.
That's not what she was doing.
She looks like her mouth
is completely closed.
Yeah. This is not,
WikiHow is off, off, off the rails.
Touch your teeth together.
Make sure your tongue can move.
Look at yourself in the mirror.
What?
You should not be able to see your tongue.
You should be able to see your teeth.
Your mouth's not closed!
Yeah. This is bullcrap, man.
I don't want to just,
Breathe normally.
I think it's just magic.
Oh, so we're back to that.
I think that that is,
It's not weird, man.
I think you're a freak, Katelin.
I think you are a freak
and there, you know,
there's others.
You can find them and
then keep it to yourself.
You can speak to each other that way.
But it's impressive.
What I'm saying, is this a good,
That's a legit party trick.
That's not like flossing with
your, with your fingernails.
Yeah. Yeah.
This isn't something you do by yourself.
This is something you do in
the company of other people
and they're impressed and they ask,
Okay.
Questions about,
So you're a freak, but
no, you're not weird.
Yeah.
You're talented.
Talented, exactly.
High responded,
That's,
an unpronounceable,
bxndtrxsh4
said,
"I can't watch any show.
Am I weird because I can't watch any show
unless I know what happens first. Like,
if I'm watching an episode of some show,
I have to Google what
happens before I finish it
or I get nervous.
And then I can't watch
the rest of the episode
because I'm too tense
about what might happen.
Even jeopardy.
You know those jeopardy episodes.
Wow. Well, I'll tell ya,
the Jeopardy always ends
in one of three ways.
One of the three people wins.
I can't, can you imagine having to
Google the episode of
Jeopardy you're watching?
Can you get that information? I mean,
it's probably, it's probably in Wiki.
I mean like the TiVo or whatever would say
the episode number and then,
I gotta know who's gonna win this one.
But then somebody responded,
Jennifer Sanford responded
to this tweet and said,
"OMG. I thought I was the
only one who did this.
My brother definitely thinks
I'm weird when I do this.
Okay.
Can I just give you my
knee jerk reaction to this?
Sure.
I'm not a therapist. I have
been in therapy for some time.
Not the same thing.
That's why I'm saying it as a disclaimer,
this has got, this is
something about control.
I mean, there there's something
about, I, I don't know.
It's related to,
The unknown.
Uncertainty. Insecurity.
It's too much to handle.
Too much to take.
But it feels like is an example of,
what do you call it when you,
is it called exposure therapy?
Like when you're afraid of something
and then you expose yourself to it
in order to overcome it.
This feels, and again, I'm not you.
I don't understand this personally,
There's not a spider down your pants.
And I'm,
That's a double meaning exposure therapy.
If this is a real,
like, if this is like
a super anxious thing
and I'm not giving you medical
or psychological advice,
but it feels like, at least
with an episode of Jeopardy
might be a good place to start.
Like I think,
I think you can make it
through an episode of Jeopardy.
Well, who are you to say?
And let the, I'm just saying,
If you can't,
I think you might need to
talk it out with somebody.
Is really what, I agree with that.
Yeah. I think that's what I'm getting at.
Yeah, ah,
This is not this isn't, I
wouldn't say weird though,
because I feel like
that makes it, you know,
Judgey,
you don't want to judge somebody
or dealing with something
that's, you know, that
might require therapy.
But I'm sympathetic.
I'm sympathetic to this.
And I feel like it's something that you,
that you shouldn't have
to go through life with.
This is a sign of a,
of a,
of a deeper issue,
which maybe you're cool with it.
Or maybe you want to look into it.
I would have to think that this tendency
has to play itself out into
just life in general, right?
Like, so this would be like, I mean,
every single day is a
Jeopardy episode, right?
Every single day is a day in which
you don't know what
Trebeck's going to say.
You don't know who's going to win.
You don't know what's going
to happen in your life,
but you don't have the
ability to go and see.
But you know when,
See if this person,
who tweeted and I can't
pronounce their username
is listening now
and they didn't realize
what you're saying,
boy, you've just made
it a whole lot worse.
But here's the thing,
I think I can actually in a
weird way, relate to this.
It's just something that's coming to me.
So, you know, we've talked in the past
about how I actually am much more,
there's a lot more going on emotionally
than I ever realized until
I started going to therapy.
And one of the ways that
my emotions come out
is in things that feel
like there's not any stakes
and I'm not personally invested in.
IE television and movies
and commercials, right?
I'll cry in all those scenarios.
Yeah.
Because it's not personal.
So I think that this
particular person, "High",
might be like, I can't deal with the fact
that I've got uncertainty in my life,
but when I expose myself
to an episode of Jeopardy
or some, some show,
I know that the,
the outcome does exist.
I can Google the outcome
and I can gain a little bit
of security and control in this thing.
And then in a way that I can't do in life.
And that brings me a
sense of security, right?
Yeah.
And so, that's my theory
as to what's going on.
So,
But if it, yeah,
If you can get to a place
where you can embrace
an episode of Jeopardy, not knowing
which of the three people is going to win,
I guess sometimes there's a tie.
Um,
Is that possible?
Can there be a tie and it
rolls over to next episode?
No, I don't think so.
Okay. So somebody's going to win.
If you can just let that ride,
then maybe you can get a little bit more,
a little bit better at dealing
with just a typical day.
I don't know. I'm not a professional.
Take it or leave it. Take
it with a grain of salt.
Since November, 2014 ties for first place,
following Final Jeopardy are
broken with a breaker clue
resulting in only a single
champion being named,
keeping their winnings and returning
to compete in the next show.
If no contestant finishes Final Jeopardy
with a positive total, there is no winner.
So there could be,
So there's a fourth option.
There could be three losers.
How many times has that happened?
Jeopardy just got more interesting.
And that was only since 2014.
I mean, how could three
people go into Final Jeopardy
and make wagers that put
them in the negative?
That means somebody's not playing right.
Somebody's making a bad decision.
On March 2nd, 2018
Jeopardy history was made
when two contestants competed
during the final tournament
of Thursday's episode.
While all three of the show's competitors
wrote in the wrong, wrote
in wrong submissions
for the channel islands prompt,
Laura and Sarah found themselves in a tie
which led to the first ever
Final Jeopardy tiebreaker.
First ever.
And then how did they do the tie breaker?
It's just another question.
With another wager.
With a tiebreaker clue.
Oh!
Are broken with a tiebreaker clue.
So is it a clue about the same question?
You get a hint? Like G&M?
Yeah, that seems a little lame.
I mean, we would never do that.
Yeah I think there's something,
just to get back to
the question, you know,
with all the Googling I'm doing today,
I did some preemptive Googling
when I picked this question
and I could not find something to Google
that would bring up people
who related to this.
Unlike the rubbing your feet
together. You know, it's,
I can't, I can't, I can't Google are you,
do you have to look up the results of,
of a show before you can watch it?
I know people who read
and I, and I've done this,
I Googled that, but nothing came up.
As a kid I would look at like
the last sentence of a book.
But it was for like a different reason.
It wasn't to know how it was
going to end necessarily,
it was just because it was
there to be read. I don't know.
There's an anxiety, yeah. Yeah.
And it,
I don't do that by the way.
I don't do it anymore.
There, there there's
something going on here.
So we've successfully backed away.
It's up to you, what
you want to do with it.
We're not even going to
say if it's weird or not.
I don't think it's weird.
I think it's not weird.
Emily Little tweeted at us,
"Am I weird because I won't
watch a movie more than once?"
Okay. More of a general topic.
I feel like I'm one of these people.
Um,
I know that I'm a weird person.
So by the associative principal,
Emily, you are also weird.
No, I,
I had to work up a lot
of energy to rewatch
The Big Lebowski,
which as we established,
is both of our favorite
comedies of all time.
It had been so long since I watched it,
when we were talking
to our college friends,
they always reference it so
much. I'm like, you know what?
I'd like to see this
after like over a decade
of not watching it.
But I rarely,
and I always thought it
was like movie lovers
and people who were like,
really like students of film,
they should watch the same
movie again and again,
I mean, you don't gain, you
gain insight through that.
But like a normal viewer,
I just haven't related to it.
I feel like there's so
much stuff out there. I,
it's hard for me to justify to
myself the investment of time
to rewatch something that I know,
already know what's gonna happen.
Kind of to the last point.
Yeah, I,
It's not as fun.
I don't, I mean, this here's,
here's what I find interesting
about this situation
between me and you is that,
you know I don't watch
the same movie twice.
I don't do the same thing twice.
I don't eat the same meal twice.
I don't go to the same restaurant twice.
I don't go to the same
city on vacation twice.
But interestingly, you do that, right?
Yeah.
Like you guys will go to
the same place on vacation.
Like you find something that you like.
But it's not the same experience.
Watching the show is a
different experience.
It's, it's,
it's not, it's a compromised experience.
Like the surprise of
what's going to happen.
Cause I'm also, you know,
I'm the stickler of sticklers
when it comes to trailers.
I mean, spoilers.
Well, trailers.
And trailers.
Like, I don't watch trailers
of movies I'm gonna watch.
I don't wanna read anything about them,
if I know I'm going to watch it.
Because it just takes
away from the experience.
Like it annoys me, anything built,
any marketing built around a work of art,
is to me a spoiler of some
aspect of that experience
that the artists wanted to create.
Yeah.
And it's annoying to me.
I'm not spoiler sensitive.
Like it doesn't,
it doesn't ruin it for me. But it, to me,
the principle that I applied
to media is the same thing
that I apply to a restaurant.
It's like, back when we
used to go to restaurants
on a regular basis in Los Angeles.
Like Jesse and I would very rarely
go to the same place twice because,
I'm just like,
I'm in one of the biggest
cities in the world.
There's always a new place.
And we both think like that.
And so we're just like,
it doesn't always result in a better meal.
No.
Often it's just like, Hmm.
But I think when I look at
movies or TV shows or whatever,
I just think, Oh,
there's, and I don't just,
like you were saying, it's like,
if you're going to take the
time to devote two hours
of your evening to something, it's like,
why devote to the same thing?
However, the other night at your house.
Yeah.
We watched,
We rewatched a movie.
And the funny thing is, is when,
That was your idea, by the way.
When y'all said that we
were going to watch Us,
the movie.
I, my, I wasn't excited about it.
As much as I absolutely love that movie.
I've only seen it once.
I, I wasn't excited about it,
but I had an incredible
time rewatching that movie.
So it made me actually think
twice about rewatching movies.
Well, that movie is
specifically constructed that,
Bless you.
Is there going to be eight more?
I just want to know.
I dunno.
There might be one more, at least.
Jordan Peele constructed
this movie in such a way
that once you, once you've
watched it, you have.
You know what to watch for.
You have a different
experience watching it
the second time.
I believe a movie with a reveal
is a completely different experience.
I think that's, that's
something that hit me.
It was like, Oh man.
Like if you watch a movie
with a significant reveal
of some kind or a twist,
you should watch it again.
Rewatch it.
Now, do you think that saying
that a movie has a twist
is a spoiler? Does that
violate your spoiler?
Absolutely.
Yes.
Spoiler alert.
A little late.
Hmm. Yeah, that doesn't track with me,
but I'm sorry if,
if I ruined Us for you.
That is, that is a huge,
to say that there's a twist at the end.
Or a reveal.
But how many movies?
So many movies have reveals.
Almost all movies have reveals except
just like straight dramas.
Like with,
all right I'm gonna make a,
spoiler alert for Mandalorian season two.
Okay?
So you can skip,
I have not,
I haven't watched the first episode.
Fifteen seconds.
You're not gonna ruin it for me.
I watched it the night,
that's why I'm telling you,
but I wouldn't want you to tell me this.
Okay.
But on, like the Twitter moments,
the day after the
Mandalorian episode came out,
it said "Mandalorian, season two,
premiers with an amazing
character reveal."
Well, of course,
they're going to tell you
who the Mandalorian is.
I mean,
you can go a second season,
not knowing who the,
the actor who plays him?
Which by the way,
I saw an article about
the actor who plays him
before I ever watched the
season. Before I got started.
Okay. Well, I don't want to,
you know, in an effort, well,
I hate to spoil more,
but I just can't help
myself to just tell you
that you're wrong.
Okay. But he will be revealed.
Well, that's not what we're talking about.
My point is, they said that
there's an amazing character reveal. You,
you misinterpreted it.
And I knew the answer,
but I think that again,
I would not have wanted to know that.
And I'm just glad I had
already watched the episode.
So that's why I make sure
that I'll watch it episode
right when it comes out.
Is it like that baby Yoda
has like a spider body
or something like that?
All right.
I told them to skip forward 15 seconds.
We're not talking about it anymore.
So we don't think that Emily is weird
because she won't watch
a movie more than once.
But there are, I think
there's some exceptions.
Yeah. How about Scnozamanian.
"Am I weird because I
asked people to repeat
what they have to me,
even though I heard them loud and clear.
I just do. And it's
completely out of my control.
It's completely out of your control.
We knew somebody like this.
Scnozamanian,
I'm just going to tell you that,
I, I feel a little anger welling up inside
when I read your confession.
I mean, it's.
Well,
and the person that I'm
thinking about right now,
who we both know from our past,
who will remain nameless.
I don't know who you're talking about.
Can you,
Huh?
Just,
I almost remember, but I don't.
Huh?
Like,
I know that there was
this person in our lives,
Huh?
but I can't remember.
Oh!
Are you talking about the,
Back from our high school days.
Oh, I thought you were,
He was older than us.
He was in college when
we were in high school.
Huh?
Just tell me and we'll
have to bleep it out.
Uh,
Say it!
Oh yeah! He did do that.
Huh?
While you were talking.
How long? No matter what you said,
no matter at what point you were in
and what you were saying.
Huh? He said, "huh?"
And I guarantee you he,
It was infuriating.
He was hearing you. The whole time.
Huh?
So I don't know,
I don't know if this is what you do,
Schnoz, if this is what you do,
you need to stop it immediately.
Yeah. That's not,
And you say you can't,
it's out of my control.
I think that's a lie.
That you're telling yourself.
What causes that?
Huh?
Do you remember it?
And it doesn't have, I do now. Yeah.
And it maybe Schnoz doesn't
like constantly give the "Huh?",
but even if it's like, "What
was that?", when you're done.
What'd you say?
How could that even happen?
Oh, I,
Now
I dunno.
When my kids, when my kids were younger,
like I seem to recall
having an experience,
a parenting experience. So I'm like,
they'll,
there was a phase that I think
Lily and Lincoln went through
where they would be like, "What?"
And I remember deciding
to start to say, hold on,
You heard me.
Hold on. You heard me.
What, what did you hear?
And by the way,
and we forced them,
I forced them to say,
cause it was
in their brains.
Yeah, I did. I did hear it.
It's like they have to
replay it, and then.
Well the same things happens,
it does go both ways, I mean,
how many times have my
kids asked me something
and I've just, I never
thought I would be this,
but it turns out this is
just what being a dad is.
It's your kids asking you,
You're asleep in a recliner
with a remote on your crotch.
I'm not asleep. I'm just
doing what dad wants to do.
And when children ask questions of me,
I do not. I'm impervious to them.
It's filtered.
And so they're like, "Dad, you heard me!"
And then I do the same
thing. And I'm like,
"Oh, I did hear you."
Yeah. I, it is in my brain,
but I had not reckoned with it until now.
So this goes both ways.
This is not a good practice for anyone.
I mean, you've, you've
got to just take a beat
and say, I'm about to ask
them to repeat themselves,
but did I just, did I actually hear it?
Yes I did.
I'm hearing it again now in my memory.
I'm responding to it.
Yeah.
I'm not burdening somebody
to say something again.
And I don't think this is weird.
I think this is, based on my experience,
this is just annoying.
You know, to be completely
harsh and honest about it.
Again, and I'm just going off of
my personal experience with it,
from this one person.
Well that might be our next,
"Am I annoying because I blank?"
Okay. Yeah.
We can keep going down this rabbit hole.
Laura, LaRawwwr!
Said, "Am I weird because
I eat raw pasta as a snack?
The crunch when you bite,
it is so satisfying.
Like a hard candy, but it's savory."
I've,
I've eaten a,
a taut strand of spaghetti before.
Taught?
And I felt like,
I felt like it was
going to break my tooth.
Was it? And it was a spaghetti?
Yeah.
Or your try linguini?
I didn't try, I only tried spaghetti.
And I mean,
there's a bit of danger involved.
It's kind of like chewing glass
and the taste is very subtle.
You might be overstating the danger,
but this just seems like a preference.
I mean, there are, okay,
I remember one time I went
over to Peter Dinklage's house
and you know, it sounds like a name drop,
but that was just my neighbor growing up,
a different one.
And he went into the fridge
and grabbed a hot dog cold,
which he called a raw hotdog.
And this is before I really understood
that hot dogs were pre cooked.
Yeah?
And he just ate it out of the fridge.
And I was like,
he's weird. He eats raw hot dogs.
But you know me, one night in my house,
curiosity got the best of me.
And I ate a raw hotdog,
and I was like, ah,
I kinda get this. I sorta get this.
But it might make me weird.
I don't think I would
enjoy it now. But as a kid,
I would do that.
I think eating uncooked
pasta is more strange,
um,
because it's,
it's so,
I mean, I like a good crunch,
but the crunch is so intense.
There are other things are
that crunchy and savory.
Like crackers, chips.
But nothing is as crunchy
as uncooked pasta.
But there are things made
from wheat that are crunchy,
like a Wheat Thin.
Like a Wheat Thin feels like
you're getting close to
just eating straight pasta,
but it's been made into a form.
So I think you should maybe
just switch to Wheat Thins.
I disagree. The more I think about it,
I can't think of anything
that you could eat
that is crunchier than uncooked pasta.
I mean, it's,
it's almost like glass.
You think I'm exaggerating,
but have you done it?
You ever eaten raw pasta?
I'm sure I have at one point.
Well not raw, but uncooked.
But also, there's no flavor to it.
Like, it hasn't been salted.
It's as hard as it, as a fingernail.
Can you floss with it?
That's the truth, man.
I mean, it's brittle, but
it's, but it's as hard.
If that makes sense.
I think this is a,
is this weird?
I get the crunch. Like if
you need an extreme crunch,
I can't think of anything
that's going to rival that, Laura.
So I'm going to say, that it's not weird.
I'm gonna say you're you,
you've got to crunch fetish
and I think you should
explore other things.
I think that this is weird, but it's okay.
You know what I'm saying? Like.
Yeah. That's why I use the word fetish.
I think that's what fetish
means to me. Weird, but okay.
No judgment.
Okay. Well, if, if,
if I was inventing a character for a story
and you know, there's the principle
that Blake Snyder talks about,
you know, a limp and an eye patch,
you give every character in a narrative
something notable makes
them a little bit different.
Okay.
I think that this
character eats raw pasta.
Yeah. That's a, that's
a good character trait.
That's fun,
To me, it's sort a quirky.
I would say I would get
into, I think it's weird,
but it's good weird.
That's my conclusion.
Margaret.
All right so,
we disagree.
Stivers or Stivers?
"Am I weird because I
like to mix baked beans
with cottage cheese?"
Now this is a mixture of worlds.
On a, on a recent carpool vlog,
we do videos for the Mythical
Society where we like, we,
we were riding in the car.
It's like a 20 minute video
where we're just shooting the breeze.
Sometimes we do answer questions, but,
I don't know how it came up, but
I shared with you that I'm obsessed,
my favorite type of cheese
right now, is cottage cheese.
I love it.
I love to put a bowl of that sloppy oozy,
white,
crumb. Like what are those like nodules
of cottage cheese in a bowl,
throw some walnuts on it.
I'm surprised.
Dried blueberries.
I'm surprised that you like it
because you kind of get grossed out
by cheese sometimes.
And I think cottage cheese,
while I also like it,
It's like, it's like,
It feels like
the grossest kind of cheese
besides maybe blue cheese.
It's like a cereal. It
doesn't, it tastes bland.
It's in a bowl. I eat it with a spoon.
Why is it called cottage?
It has like,
a cereal experience.
But with protein.
Have you ever had it in a cottage?
Ah,
I fancy my house a cottage.
Why is it a cottage?
Is it made in cottages?
Or is it made from a region
that has a lot of cottages?
All right, man.
I mean, I'm, I've been
pretty good at Googling.
"Why it's called cottage cheese?"
It is made from different types of milk
with different fat levels.
The term cottage cheese is
believed to have originated
because the cheese was
generally made in cottages
from milk leftover after making butter.
The cheese is creamy
lumpy and sold in pots.
Cottage, this is
this is from cheese.com, by the way.
I think. Okay.
The way I'm interpreting
what you just read
is that more traditional cheese,
like say a cheddar, is
a result of a process,
an intentional process,
like by a cheese maker.
But cottage cheese is like cheese
that happened at
somebody's house in a more,
this is leftover, kind
of accidental way almost.
Cottage cheese is thought
to be the first cheese
made in America.
Yeah. This is making lots of sense.
For centuries, farmers in Europe
made fresh farmhouse cheeses
with naturally soured milk
after separating the curds from the whey.
Immigrants to America
brought the tradition
of fresh cheese making with them.
And by the mid 1800s,
the term cottage cheese entered
the American vocabulary.
Cottage cheese is sold both plain.
It's the original cheese.
Cottage cheese is the
original American cheese?
Yeah, just like me.
Sorry. I'm sniffing man.
You should.
I think we have Zyrtec here at the office.
I'm gonna get some in a second.
I didn't think that
withdrawal would be this bad.
I read a whole Reddit thread
about Zyrtec withdraw.
Some people have crazy itching happen.
It's not happening to me.
I just got this sniffys.
What do your toenails smell like?
That's going to be an indicator.
Probably couldn't smell them right now.
I was also told that eating cottage cheese
before you go to bed is good,
Dreams.
Is good for, no,
it's a good way to get the type of protein
Casein.
that your body needs when you're sleeping.
Casein, slow release protein.
I mean, the theory is,
because unlike whey protein,
which is an immediate release,
which is you should do like
right after your workout
cause your muscles are hungry for it.
You take casein before
you go to sleep, which,
and you can buy casein just as a powder.
Sometimes I'll drink like the thing.
Get it in the cottage.
Maybe I should just the cottage cheese
and also dairy.
Before you go to sleep.
My experience is causes
you to have crazy dreams.
Hmm?
I don't know what the connection is there.
So two for one, cause I'm
starting to eat cottage cheese.
But, the question was
mixing beans with cottage.
That is weird.
That, yeah, that's weird.
I've never heard of that.
Beans and cheese. Bean and cheese burrito.
That's a thing.
Yeah.
But beans and cottage cheese
is not warm. Cottage cheese is cold.
I mean, if I search
beans and cottage cheese.
"What compliments cottage
cheese?" people ask.
Sliced bananas, crushed pineapple,
berries, melon chunks,
fresh peaches.
Everything is sweet.
Everything that compliments
cottage cheese is sweet.
Yeah, nothing.
I mean food.com has a pork and beans
with cottage cheese recipe.
I think, if it becomes more
like a cream cheese thing,
then maybe that could be good.
This is, this is the mix.
This is the melding of our worlds, Ret.
I bring the cottage. You bring the beans,
let's get together and make a scene.
Do you heat the cottage cheese up?
I mean, it's a, this is a food.com recipe.
How many reviews is it?
By Jeff Hammer.
I think this is user generated.
Did anybody comment on this?
Yeah, no only Jeff commented.
Oh! Nope. Down here.
Don Kaye.
He said don't cook the beans.
Okay.
I don't know. There's not many people.
It's not, food.com is not
a cauldron of conversation.
Apparently.
So, I'm going to say this is, this is,
this is weird.
And I'm going to go there as well.
I think this is weird.
I mean, you don't want to try it.
Oh, I'll try it.
I gotta sneeze again.
Okay.
You probably just
deposited something on
your right shoulder.
People are going to think
you've got the COVID, man.
I don't man. It's allergies.
This happens every time I
run out of my allergy pills.
All right, Laura, you're weird.
Margaret. You're weird.
Let's get to Mary, quite contrary.
"Am I a weird because I hit
myself when I see a crow?
because I think it gets
rid of, I wanna say blad,
because I think it gets rid of bad luck.
So If I see four, I hit myself four times.
If I see 20, yep, 20 taps on my chest."
Okay, she moved from hitting to tapping.
Which, that's good.
"I'm aware that it is
irrational. And I try not to,
but I can't help it. #earbiscuits"
So this is obviously a
compulsive superstition, right?
Yeah.
So, yeah.
It's just,
I don't think it makes you weird.
I mean, knocking on wood,
but freaking,
I mean, like to me this
is kind of like punch bug.
Like if you're in the car
and you're like, you know,
when me and my mom used to,
used to ride in the car
together, if we saw a punch bug,
you'd say, you saw a
Volkswagen bug on the road
and whatever color it was
say, "punch bug blue!"
If you were the first
person and you'd punch him,
punch him on the shoulder.
So I would punch my mom on the shoulder.
But she would also punch
me on the shoulder.
It was kind of like a love lick.
To me that's more about bonding.
That's a social experiment.
That's a social bonding.
That works. But then,
This is something, this
is a compulsive behavior.
Is it not?
Yeah. It's just,
I can't make sense out of it,
It doesn't make you weird,
it makes you actually pretty,
I mean, this is very
common. This is very normal.
Everyone has compulsive behavior.
Some are more pronounced
than others. Some cross into,
as you have described,
irrationality and superstition.
Like when I would feed my dog, Tucker,
I would always feed him
and I would pat him on
the head five times.
I would count.
Five times. Pat, Pat, Pat, Pat, Pat.
And then I would feel like, okay,
my job is complete.
I patted him four times.
He's gotten what he needs.
Five times.
_ Five times.
I don't think this,
I don't think this is
weird. And I, and I don't,
and I don't think that
it is necessarily bad
unless it becomes, if it's
in other areas of your life.
I mean, my wife, you know,
struggles with OCD, not,
she doesn't have this
particular type. Right?
But it's not, it's very difficult to like,
you don't like really get rid of it.
Like, you are always someone
who struggles with it.
And I'm not saying that this
isn't necessarily what it is,
but like, there's a number of behaviors,
like tapping your dog four
times or tapping your chest
when you see a crow that,
I feel like there's a little
bit of self-soothing in this.
It's not necessarily
some debilitating thing.
You know?
But
you probably,
you probably could help it
if you really wanted to.
But I don't necessarily
know that it's like,
this is like a something
that you have to address
in order to move on in life.
But the belief of thinking
that it gets rid of bad luck.
That's just incorrect.
Yeah.
But that don't
make you weird.
It seems like it's, you know,
from the outside looking in,
without knowing anything
and not passing judgment,
but just saying, you know,
isn't this an unnecessary
constraint on your life,
to have to, to know that this isn't true.
But then it's like, now
you're tapping yourself
and you don't, you know,
you don't feel soothed.
Is it something that you
want to change? Perhaps?
Well, I mean, what about like,
It's your call? Not ours.
I mean, what about like a baseball player?
You know, they're
notoriously superstitious.
He wears a certain pair of socks.
You're talking about cricket, right?
Yeah, a cricket player who wears
the same pair of underwear until he loses
or something like that.
Um,
I guess I'm in the, if
this isn't hurting anybody.
Yeah, it's fun. And it
gives you confidence.
You know, I got the, I got my
lucky pair of tiger underwear.
Or like our lucky shirts.
I haven't worn them in a long time.
Our lucky shirts that we wear for
the GMM countdown episodes, which, I mean,
of course we don't believe
that there's luck in them.
We're doing a bit, but I
mean, if we did believe it,
it wouldn't be weird. It
would just be superstitious.
It's fun. It's like, I mean,
but lucky underwear or something like that
gives you confidence.
There's a psychological thing that like,
then you can,
you can hit the cricket ball
or puck or whatever it is.
You know, you can bat better.
But like thinking,
Believing something that isn't true.
Isn't necessarily bad. I guess
is what I'm saying. Right?
Like the, and again,
If it makes you feel better.
Well, it can also,
If it doesn't hurt anybody.
It can also,
you know, he talks about
this in the book Sapiens,
like that's actually one of the things
that makes humans, humans,
and the ability to
cooperate with each other
is the fact that we can believe a fiction
that like bonds us together.
We can believe things that are not true,
about ourselves or about other people.
And it can be advantageous.
So I'm not saying that that's
necessarily what's happening
with a superstition,
but I'm just saying that
I don't think it's bad necessarily
to believe something that's not true.
If it helps you, or
helps a group of people,
as long as it's not hurting somebody.
Because our grasp of what is actually true
is actually,
it's not as keen as we all think it is.
Yeah. Cause we could find
out one day that, you know.
Tapping yourself when crows
show up is really awesome.
That it really does counteract
the bad luck. That is real.
That all crows carry.
They are smart.
And they're a lot bigger than you think.
What if,
If you get right up on
a crow, they're big.
They could peck your eye out.
What if this person goes and watches,
watches The Black Crows in concert?
And they tap along with the beat.
♪ Let me light your candle ♪
♪ Cause I'm so hard to handle ♪
♪ Yes, I am. ♪
You've turned it into,
some sort of like strange chant.
Cottoneye Joe.
Oh yeah, that too.
Just yourself be, if weird is you.
This celebration is now concluded.
Yeah. Listen, I mean,
we made some judgements,
but we told you that's
what we were going to do.
Spoiler alert.
And you know, I think we'll do this again.
Shall I make a rec?
You shall.
Okay, I made this rec to you.
I'm going to make it to you.
You know, if it's good
enough for my friend
it's good enough for you.
You, you gotta have Apple,
you gotta have the Apple TV
plus subscription to watch this.
So if you have that,
definitely check it out.
The Beastie Boys Story.
Beastie Boys Story,
there was a book that was
written by Adam Horowitz
and Mike D.
Adam Jaak. He, you know, he passed away.
The Beastie Boys were technically no more.
But they wrote this memoir,
which is like a super fun book.
Well, I actually didn't read the book,
I watched the documentary first
and I love the documentary so much,
now I'm going back and
listening to the book on,
on the audio book because it's,
it's really entertaining
the way it's done.
There's a lot more stories.
And they read it, they read the book?
Yeah, they do. And they
have a lot of guest stars
come in and read parts of the book too.
Lots of people fans of the Beastie Boys.
And the thing that, you know,
I encourage you to watch it.
You know, it's,
it's like an hour and a half.
It's, they call it a live documentary.
It's a stage show. I mean,
if you saw the tour Mythicality,
which was the stage show version
of the book of Mythicality,
what they did was very similar, you know.
They definitely stole our idea.
It was the two, it was
the two of them on stage
with a screen behind them,
and they would just cut to like visuals
to support their stories.
And they just told their story and it was,
you know, it's scripted and
it's a little stilted at times
and they like used a prompter.
It actually made me feel good that like,
Hey, they did something
very similar to us.
And,
they tell the story of their friendship.
Friendship is such a strong theme.
So even if you're, if you're
not a fan of their music,
I would say the first half is, you know,
they go chronological.
It's about, you know,
how the band started and
it's, it's a crazy story.
But it's really the second
half of the documentary,
wouldn't you agree where
it really starts to sing?
Like once they achieve their initial fame,
and then,
I just related to it so much from a,
from a creative standpoint,
like working closely
with a lifelong friend of mine
and having to,
having to pivot from early successes
to find later successes in their career.
And just the,
it was very inspiring to me because
I related to so much of it.
Yeah. I thought it was great.
I mean, I, I didn't know,
I knew so little about them.
And the thing we talked about
is we were trying to figure out
why we weren't more of a fan
All along the way. Yeah.
Like, especially like in the nineties
when we were in high school,
because we were like
listening to 311 and I mean,
311 is no Beastie Boys.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
It's just interesting that
that's what we gravitated
towards, but fascinating story.
Just the way things
worked back in the day,
in the music industry and the
way things kind of came up
with like a new genre being invented.
So I think, I mean, I enjoyed all of it.
I thought the beginning was awesome too,
because it's just fascinating to see
how all that came together
back in the MTV days
and the way it worked.
So foreign.
The thing that I really appreciated was,
they processed their entire experience
through a lens of like a maturity
that they grew into over time. You know?
They said,
it's not that we became adults
as much as we kinda just
gained some maturity, you know,
In a lot of ways that I don't think in,
in a way that I relate
to, in a lot of ways
I don't feel like an adult,
but I feel like I have this,
I can look back on our
career with like this level
of maturity and, you know,
we haven't pivoted as much as they did.
You know, from this, their
first album and like the
becoming this, becoming the trope
that they were making
fun of while on tour,
like this fight for your
right to party guys,
and then coming to grips with
how that wasn't who they truly were.
I just really enjoyed how
they processed it and,
and presented it with like
this retrospective wisdom.
That, I didn't know, I
didn't know was there.
It's like, you know that Adam Jaak,
you know, he became this
crusader for, for Tibet
and you know,
he's a fascinating guy
and you get to know him
through the lens of his, of,
of his friends talking about him,
which I thought was really cool too.
Yeah.
So it was a great tribute to him.
It's very moving.
If you liked the tour Mythicality,
I think, you know, and if I could see,
I can see how mythical beasts process us,
I kind of put myself
in their shoes and it,
because,
You put less pressure on.
In being a fan of the Beastie Boys.
Performers in that moment,
because you're kind of
taking in their story.
Yeah. And I started to,
I really understood each of them as an,
as an individual
and began to understand
their personalities.
And I felt like I got to know them
and appreciate who they were.
And then,
in going back and
listening to those albums
that we should have been
into, you're right, before.
I had this appreciation for the albums,
because I had an appreciation
for who they were as people
and the journeys that they had been on.
And I,
I feel good that I've,
that we've given,
we've given that to Mythical Beast.
You know? We brought them,
they understand our journey.
They know us as people,
they know our quirks,
they know our differences.
They know, they know what,
what makes us work together.
And they're pulling for us
in the way that I was pulling
for them in their story.
So when, when it seemed like they broke up
without even talking about it, that was,
that was a great point.
Spoiler alert!
So to see what happened
from that, in that moment, you know?
And how they're just, they were,
they're just real people.
Yeah.
And they put it all out there.
So.
The Beastie Boys Story.
Beastie Boys Story.
Recommended.
Now what?
Well we just say, #earbiscuits
to continue to conversation
on the interwebs.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist
on the right to watch.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon
to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.